let's go to the 908 area code call her
from 908 who's this where are you
calling from hey how's it going mr.
Pakman my name is Paul happy new year by
the way thank you Paul go ahead what's
on your mind I just had a quick question
about the the Trump bug because
obviously we all seen we all seen the
Trump bug and it's spreading through the
right and we've seen it trickle down a
little bit to the to the left but now
it's even to the per new progressive
left with Rashida to live we've seen her
just recently used the foul language
while making a speech you think that's
potentially damaging to to the political
climate of the new of the new left
okay so let's break that down into a
couple pieces when you say you've seen
the Trump bug spread to the right and
then to the left do you mean being in
favor of Trump or being against Trump
you know the attitude the Trump attitude
as I guess saying that he doesn't he
doesn't he doesn't mind what he says he
says whatever he wants and we seem to
get away with it so okay it's wondering
what you think of the new left or the
new progressive left so let's take the
example you Gabe you're talking about
Rasheeda Talib and what what is it that
she said she said that I don't know if I
don't want you saw language on your show
but she said we were gonna we're going
to impeach this mother-effer oh listen I
don't care about so okay I have problems
with Rasheeda Talib and and they have to
do with her political positions she's
part of an and identity politics she's
part of a left that I don't identify
with but I don't care about swearing I
mean you know I've said before swearing
is just not a big deal I I'm from
Argentina people saw her on TV there
it's just it's just not a huge deal it's
not taboo I have no per the question for
me is not that she said let's impeach
this mf'er my problem is that she is not
being clear about what information she's
using to make the assessment that he's
going to be impeached like defend the
impeachment part not the I have no
problem with the language that she used
mmm
all right well so you you don't have a
problem with the language you just
wishes you just wish that she would be
more specific
instead of using her emotion you'd be
more professional about the way she
approaches no I'm not even saying
anything about her professionals I'm
just saying if you are an elected a
member of Congress and I'm guessing that
she said this before she was sworn in
yesterday or was it after the
swearing-in because when she was wearing
it when she okay
just explain how the impeachment process
will work what he will be impeached for
and then importantly how you will get
Republicans in the Senate to vote for
his eventual removal like tell me that
use whatever language you want I don't
care
mm-hmm okay thank you appreciate the
call very much